c'est un nouveau gouvernement sans
réelle surprise qu'ont découvert les
algériens presque un mois après
l'échéance législatives du 12 juin
marqué par un taux d'abstention de 77%
et une répression sans précédent du
principal mouvement contestataire le
irak de présidente et bull a dévoilé la
composition de l'équipe gouvernementale
est ce le ministère régalien a changé
sont ceux des affaires étrangères et de
la justice pour le reste c'est le statu
quo sur la nouvelle équipe composée de
34 membres dont quatre femmes seulement
17 ministres ont été reconduits dont
ceux de l'intérieur la santé ou encore
l'énergie
un immobilisme certains qui semble
cristalliser l'impasse politique dont
souffre le pays depuis le début du
soulèvement populaire du irak en 2019 ce
nouveau gouvernement loin de répondre
aux aspirations du peuple algérien met
plutôt en exergue les ratés du pouvoir
en place
écoutez à ce propos l'analyse du
politologue et dahmane abdelkrim si l'on
se réfère à l'effet d'annoncé on est en
droit de se demander si ce sens va pas
être simple remake
maintenant la situation est quand même
assez particulier les enjeux sont
terribles sur le plan politique
même s'il est dans une forme de la
france par intermittence entre
l'expression les enjeux économiques sont
en sang terrible les enjeux sécuritaires
ce qui se passe en libye ce dans le
sahel et c'est un peu tous ces éléments
là peut-être qu'ils ont probablement
donné une incidence sur synergie
le gouvernement indien est aujourd'hui
plus que déterminé à poursuivre sa
normalisation politique et
institutionnel tout en ignorant les
revendications de la rue plus de 300
personnes sont actuellement en prison
qu'ils soient en lien avec le irak ou
défenseurs des libertés individuelles
selon le comité national de libération
des détenus la nouvelle assemblée quant
à elle doit prendre ses fonctions ce
jeudi